but first it's not being the eve but
first it's not been the easiest campaign
for the lib dems either the poll
suggests they're being squeezed by the
two main parties as we approach polling
day on thursday
well joining us now is their party
leader jay swinson thank you very much
for being
with us always good to chat with you
sophie how do you think the campaign is
going
well i'm looking forward to liberal
democrats making real progress
of the election on thursday more liberal
democrat mps
and we still have the opportunity to
stop
boris johnson getting a majority to
force through his
hard brexit deal with the real prospect
that we could be out of the eu
with no deal at all in just over a year
so the next few days will be
absolutely crucial as people make up
their minds in marginal seats across the
country
it feels like you're striking a
different tone to the one
that when we last spoke to be completely
frank last month on the show you said
i'm the candidate to be prime minister
at this election absolutely
well i'm technically still a candidate
to be prime minister obviously i'm the
liberal democrat candidate for prime
minister but now you just want to make
progress
but clearly things have changed since
the beginning of the campaign
you know when we started out we had four
political parties that had all been
floating around 20 in the polls and with
a
first-past-the-post voting system that
created a massive
opportunity and so absolutely right to
be very bold in going for that
what we've seen in the intervening weeks
is
a cozy stitch up between nigel farage
and boris johnson
those two parties now sort of
indistinguishable
and obviously that's very worrying to to
many people even those who have
supported the conservatives that now
boris johnson is nigel farage's
candidate so you've had a cozy stitch up
as well with the green party we've
applied
you you've got one you're right well i
absolutely i have worked with other
uh remain supporting parties and i'm
very proud to have done so because the
threat that we face
to our country to opportunities for
future generations from brexit is
very significant and that's why we have
worked on a cross-party basis
with other parties that want to remain
but that stitch up between
farage and johnson clearly changes the
electoral arithmetic and makes it more
difficult
um with that in mind it it feels in some
ways the
best chance the lib dems having any
influence at the election after the
election is if there's a hung parliament
scenario
if there is what would your tactics be
because i know you don't want boris
johnson in number 10 you've also said
you don't want jeremy corbyn at number
10
but what is your actual tactics when
you're faced with the reality
of the situation well we'll find out
obviously on friday morning what the
arithmetic is what has happened in the
election
and jeremy corbyn look i've said for
many reasons jeremy corbyn
is not fit to be prime minister neither
is boris johnson we've seen
in the papers today further evidence of
why that is you know 130
cases of anti-semitism in the labour
party that are outstanding you know
a party that has really failed to get to
grip
with anti-semitism under his watch as
leader that is not somebody who i could
put into
number ten there's clearly a lot of
people within the labour party who i do
work well with and have worked well with
in the last two and a half three and a
half years we have been working on a
cross-party basis to try to secure
a people's vote and that kind of
cooperation
will absolutely continue so you'd
potentially i'm just trying to read
between the lines
here are you asking for like a kind of
caretaker prime minister role if
there is a hunger i'm very open-minded
liberal democrat mps will be
absolutely focused on stopping brexit
and the more liberal democrat mps that
there are the more likely it is that we
will be able to achieve that
and of course we will work and continue
to work
with clyde country with the green party
with the smp with labor and
conservatives
who want to stop brexit put into number
10 then i'm not going to be drawing
names because we don't know what the
scenarios are going to be but i'm
setting out what our approach is going
to be
so we will be absolutely working to stop
brexit
doing so in a in a cooperative way with
others who share our values and share
that goal
and i guess what some people listen to
this might be saying is
if you acknowledge now that it's pretty
unlikely you're actually going to be
prime minister if you won't put boris
johnson into power but you also wouldn't
put jeremy corbyn into power
what's the point of voting the dem well
the point of voting liberal democrat is
to have more libbed mmps
who will work to stop brexit and in very
many
labour who won a second friend i mean
and in very many parts of the country
it's liberal democrats who are taking on
the conservatives
and whether those uh labor-minded voters
decide to back the liberal democrats in
lots of seats will help to determine
whether or not boris johnson has
a majority or whether they elect hard
brexiteers like dominic rob or john
redwood where liberal democrats can
unseat people like that so
you know the the decisions that people
make in the next few days
are really going to be important to
determine whether or not
boris johnson has a majority you said
that you want to make progress in this
election
if you end up with fewer mps than you
had when the election was called
would you then resign no i was
elected as leader of the liberal
democrats four months ago
and that's a big job to be done and you
know four months in you know i've
made a start i've already secured more
mps because of course we had
12 mps at the last general election and
we now became
leader of the party uh but there's a
there's a lot that we need to do there's
a liberal movement to build
we have backwards well look we have i
mean we have a
voting system that can you know we all
know
doesn't favor smaller parties but if we
look at the
range of um metrics the liberal democrat
party is in good health we have more
members than we have ever had in our
history of more than 30 years as a
political party
there is a movement out there of people
who share our
liberal values who want an inclusive
fair and open society
and that is what we need to build and
that is what i am focused on doing
and that's not a job that gets done in
four months bluntly sophie and so i'm
i'm i'm
absolutely here to stay and i'm excited
about the future you talk about the
voting system you're talking about nigel
farage's decision to stand down against
conservative candidates but i just
wonder
if there's a few kind of self-inflicted
mistakes that the dems have made as well
and your policy to revoke article 50
if you actually end up winning an
election so effectively cancelling
brexit i just wonder why did you decide
to adopt that did you look at polling
and
people said it was a good policy what
was the evidence behind that well i mean
it's a democratic decision by conference
it is a good policy because it's honest
about what we would do we are a party
that wants to stop brexit and
we have set out how we would do that
we've been campaigning for a people's
vote
and if we elected a lib dem majority
government obviously we would do that by
revoking article 50.
it's also a policy which which is
popular i mean if you if you look at the
yougov polls you know for people who
want to remain that's the the preferred
policy
in indeed even among labor uh remain
voters it's more popular than the labor
policy
not everyone was convinced they were
they i mean we just have a look at vince
cable for example um
the person of course who you took over
from as a party leader
he said the revoke was a distraction and
not a very helpful one uh
norman lam another of your very
long-standing mps said we are playing
with fire in many ways
and i have to say when i go around the
country it's something that comes up
quite a lot this revoke
policy and if people are perhaps put off
by jeremy corbyn and boris johnson
because they see them as
extreme candidates why did you adopt
what many people would consider to be an
extreme brexit position
well our position is that we want to
remain in the european union
and some people will think that that is
an extreme position but i think it is
about the kind of future that we want to
see for our country doing without a
referendum
is what some would see as extreme well
it's doing it through an election
so you know it is only in the
circumstances where we win a majority
which would be a democratic event
which i think many people would
recognize would be a an electoral
earthquake and therefore would have
democratic legitimacy so i i recognize
that there's people who criticize this
policy but you know generally there are
people
who want to leave the european union now
you as well have been kind of front and
center
of your campaign it's been you on the
front of the buses it's been your
picture on the leaflets
was it a mistake to run such a
presidential style of campaign
do you know what sophie i've fought lots
of different general elections and
generally it is the leader of the party
whose face is on the bus and whose
picture is on the leaflets i mean that
is what being a leader of a political
party
uh is is like and it's it's exactly what
i experienced when charles kennedy
was leader when nick clegg was leader
and so on so you know it isn't
it doesn't mean everybody i mean the
labour party for example you wouldn't
necessarily say that jeremy corbyn is on
front of every bus and every leaflet
well and you know he he he is not and
there's a story as to why that is
right and that tells you something about
even how many people in the labour party
recognize that
you know jeremy corbyn is somebody who
whether it's because he's
neutral on brexit refusing to take a
leadership position whether it's his
failure to tackle anti-semitism those
people have very real concerns about
jeremy corbyn and we can look at some of
the polling
around your approval ratings as well and
this is
um polling that we've seen uh done by
ugarven sky news
and you can see there the you know it's
almost quite difficult to kind of bring
up but you know the unfavorable ratings
they're
ticking up and up the favorable rating
staying low or dropping slightly
it almost feels like the more people see
you they the less they like you i mean
is that that
we're in an election and i'm taking a
very clear position
on brexit i want to remain in the
european union
and you know i do recognize that some
people aren't going to like that they
might not
like what i say on brexit some people
don't like what i say that i want
scotland to stay
in the united kingdom uh some people you
know don't like the way i talk or you
know what my shoes look like or whatever
else
but you know what i'm going to still
stand up for what i believe in
because i want to change things i
believe that our future can be better
our country can be better
and that is what i'm working for and
yeah some people will like it
many people do like it millions of
people want to see that future
and some people don't and that's fine
that's politics do you think some of it
is a bit sexist because you hear people
talking about
you sound like a head girl you sound a
bit bossy you sound a bit angry
sexist look i mean sophie you and i both
um
you know exist within public life where
we recognize that there are double
standards that
apply and you know i i knew that when i
took on the job
and i want things to change because if i
think about you know my
nieces growing up i want the world that
they inherit to be one that is less
sexist and one of the ways that we can
do that
is by having women in leadership roles
um blazing a trail
and i'm delighted and proud to be doing
that okay joe swinson thank you very
much for coming on the show this morning
and setting up your pitch for the
election in just a few days time thank
you
thank you